what are your top ten tips for producing
a movie top tens that's wow script
passionate about the script attack
everything you do with reckless abandon
in terms of your passion and work with
people that you get along with you have
mutual respect for both in your
profession as well as there's a personal
identification you don't have to agree
with everything but a shared shared
principle about how to work how you want
to work it's 3 right yeah 4 don't rush
things don't make artificial deadlines
that don't mean anything other than what
you think in your head and that means
like for example don't rush to get a
film done cutting corners whether it be
in the pre-production production or
post-production all to meet whatever
deadlines you have set that you have to
hit in order if it's a distributor
giving you a deadline okay if it's you
trying to get this one festival got a
really way whether or not it's worth it
to cut those corners and the reason why
I say is because in that haste to get
there you will forget certain things
that are important and it's not about
just racing to the deadline it's
thinking your plan through very clearly
so ties into that fourth fourth or fifth
part which is start from the end start
from the very end and work your way back
don't start here and go forward without
knowing where you're gonna end up and
seeing what that place looks like at the
very end when you arrive to the finished
part of your film or the distribution of
your film really and it's like it's like
a an objective a clear objective this is
where I need to be at this stage and you
should be and it should be a logical
conclusion because everything should
flow forward as it flows backwards as
well
okay you won't miss anything that way
review your budget look at your budget
daily all the time even if you're not a
guy who writes up the budget or a woman
who writes up the budget whatever it is
study it become a student of it because
you here's what it will happen and I
just know this from my own experience we
had a problem on the last film piece of
equipment got broken and would have
stopped the whole filming but knowing
that I had what I had in the budget and
knowing what I had available I knew that
we could get through it and I was able
to make a split-second decision to start
calling and getting while I was in
Riverside I had to go to LA and it was
five o'clock and everything closed at
6:00 so I had to put gamemode on I
wasn't gonna get over there so I had to
go who do we know in LA that we can have
once we purchase it they can go pick it
up and then I can go pick it up from him
later that night so then I could drive
it back to set but all of that I did
under calm when what had just unfolded
in front of me
could have been a potential disaster but
because I knew how much money I had I
knew what I needed to do I knew where to
start and I kept and we and within 30
minutes we had an answer in a solution
and it was done so so study the budget
it will benefit you in ways that you
don't even know at the time so we've got
six six well I'm sure I'm sure there are
more no I think that the the most
important thing is to have trust in the
people that you work with and that is
incumbent on you in other words you set
the table and everybody else that you
invite to that table is going to be
participating in it so that you're you
know people that you're gonna work with
for the actors and this is just when
you're doing in micro budget you don't
have lawyers and you don't have these
big you know like people to control the
behavior of others
don't necessarily go for the most
talented if it's gonna cause you a
headache if you know it's gonna cause
you a headache and see red flags I meet
with all the talent one on one after the
audition after the callback after the
final callback some of them don't like
that process that's fine but the fourth
and final one is the meeting one-on-one
and I have to know where their
motivations are what kind of person they
are not as an actor but as a person
who's gonna be a person on set and I'm
gonna be in close quarters with and I'm
going to be working with four hours long
at a time
so just think and if you don't find who
you want and it doesn't sit it doesn't
agree with you in here keep looking keep
looking till the very end go to every
avenue that you can I did this with our
leads we had we had tons of talented
actors and through the process you know
it whittled itself down and the
opportunity presented itself because I
didn't give up and in stop looking and I
found people that I just like loved and
from their profession to their to their
person and it's and I would work with
them again in a heartbeat
because if I have a role I'll do it you
know they're just great human beings and
they're wonderfully talented so I said
we're at seven eight nine and ten I
think that well I could just have two
more two more okay
gosh allow yourself to evolve with the
work that you're doing in other words
what you thought once when you started
and what happens there on out let that
be your journey that guides you in other
words let that part of the process
enrich you and give you that valuable
feedback that you want and need in order
to grow as a human being in order to
grow as an artist and in order to grow
as a filmmaker I can't say enough about
this because I think it's often that we
ignore these things about that were
human beings first and that we have
certain sensitivities and things that
bother us and issues that come up and we
all are trying if if our goal and our
focus is about the work and the
relationship to it in both ourselves and
the people that we're bringing to that
table you can achieve so much more
I personally believe this just having
the experience of doing it you can
achieve so much more people will work
that little extra harder that you've
always wanted them to do without asking
because you're leading by example and
you've brought people into that mix that
have the same same characteristic within
themselves as all of a sudden oh this
person's like this this person's like
this this pretty Oh I'm among people
like me and then we're all doing the
same thing where you have a sound guy
who's like carrying bags out of things
that are not his and being there to help
you and yeah it's just this is what what
makes it worthwhile it's not the
struggle and the all the hardships and
everything else that you have to deal
with that's fine but to override
overcome all of that and deal with it
head-on make it make it come from within
you and let that idea and that
inspiration and that passion flow and
have other people come into it who feel
that passion in you and are inspired by
it it's like this is why I got into
filmmaking I got into it for the art and
I'm hoping that that art will give me an
opportunity for more art or bigger art
or greater art or whatever it is but
this is that's probably the most
important thing I can say is that it's
allow yourself allow yourself to learn
from the process and don't be so dogged
and fixated on a specific vision that
it's not about being contrary in' or you
know throwing out what you believe but
let that belief system evolve let it
grow deeper let it get richer let it
enrich you and the people that you're
working from because at the end of the
day at the end of all of this when i am
an old
man regardless of where and up I have
all these beautiful memories of working
with people and remembering those
moments on set and how I felt and and
that is like getting to relive your life
a second time and enjoy it so I know
that maybe nine that's okay but that
that's two-in-one right now I was so
excellent so I think then that's why
with your last film I know you have two
more so a child's voice that you felt
like even at that premiere and you're
like basically closing down barn
Barney's Beanery that you felt this
energy that maybe other projects it was
good good times but there was something
different maybe yes you went by those
whatever saying I let the work guide me
and in the material and my belief system
in what we were doing with this movie
and and and the good it could do first
it wasn't about being a filmmaker in the
in the in the sense of producing and and
all the functional stuff everybody did
their job they came with their tools to
do a great job and and so it was more
about that emotion and they and that
feeling of having created something that
everybody was really proud of in
themselves not for just the craft of it
it was this like we did some we did
something oh my god it affected people
oh my god and and you know grown women
coming out and crying and and holding on
to our actors and saying I didn't know
that this this existed and that this
happened and and they don't know each
other I mean she's coming up but there
was a strong reaction I go that is so
valuable as a human human thing to
connect with another human being that
that is quote not your own and it spoke
to a deeper thing about the movie which
in the
child's voice is the calling of the
child within us and the answer to the
child that is not you or yours to say I
will protect you I will help you I will
risk my life because that that in itself
is is our mammal part the human part of
us that makes us different from a
reptile
you